[Music]  first learned about this seven years ago  on a mission in brazil to capture a  wanted fugitive  when we got there it tore through our  unit in seconds  the target has superhuman abilities  [Applause]  [Music]  it had the same marking you do cole  it's the birthmark what do you mean he  was born with it  it's not a birthmark means you've been  chosen  [Music]  throughout history different cultures  all over the world  reference a great tournament  of champions that dragon market  i think it's an invitation to fight for  something known  [Applause]  that's mortal kombat  these are your champions i'm sonya  that's kano  [Applause]  no matter how many of my people you put  in the ground  we will not fail kill them  [Music]  i am sub-zero  get over here  you [ __ ] beauty  [Music]  you